qué pasaría
si pudiéramos retroceder en el tiempo
y tomar todas esas horas de dolor
oscuridad
para reemplazarlas por algo mejor
esta niña de 7 años soñaba con ser
artista
siempre buscaba la manera de expresarse
a través del arte
recuerdo que años después se sentaba en
su computadora a crear distintas
imágenes en las cuales transmitía un
mensaje sin darse cuenta
no se daba cuenta que desde el momento
de transmitir un mensaje a las demás
personas y materializar su perspectiva
ya estaba cumpliendo con el cometido de
un artista
a los 11 años
esta niña vivió la peor situación que
puede experimentar un ser humano
la pérdida de un ser querido y esa vez
le tocó a su hermano mayor que fue
víctima de la violencia que se estaba
viviendo en culiacán sinaloa
a esa edad para esa niña era muy difícil
canalizar esos sentimientos de dolor y
sufrimiento en algo que no fuera eso en
algo que no fuera eso negativo pero ahí
fue cuando se dio cuenta como todos los
seres humanos tenemos un detonante en
nuestra vida
es algo que nos hace cambiar
s algo que nos hace entender muchas
cosas y nos hace percibir las cosas muy
diferentes
es algo que nos hace creer en nosotros o
decaer
madurar o hundirnos y que sólo depende
de como utilicemos este detonante en
nuestra vida
esta niña soy yo ya los 11 años la vida
me dio la lección más importante de toda
mi vida yo recuerdo que desde esa edad
yo trataba de contarte mi historia en
una serie de fotomontajes donde yo
trataba de materializar a una persona
que yo conocía como dios y a ese lugar
que todos conocemos como el cielo
mis papás siempre trataban de explicarme
sobre la muerte
recuerdo que gracias a ellos empecé a
entender todo esto y yo trataba de
transmitirte mi perspectiva a través de
estas imágenes que en ese entonces no
eran tan buenas pero fueron años y años
de esfuerzo hasta que llegué a hacer lo
que hago hoy en día
a mis 19 años las obras de krishna a los
11 años fueron lo que hoy marcó mi
misión de vida mi fuente de inspiración
y lo que siento que nos puede salvar a
todos el arte mi nombre es krishna
valdés y mis obras se tratan de retratos
conceptuales donde yo me siento
responsable de transmitirte mi crítica
de las cosas mi forma de ver la vida mis
sueños y hasta mis miedos
lo que comenzó con una niña de 11 años
jugando a ser artista se convirtió en
una realidad unos años después con
ciertos eventos que muchos podríamos
llamar como desafortunados para mí
sirvieron como un detonante para
realizar mi misión de vida y el cometido
que tengo hasta hoy en día
desde niños nos van haciendo creer que
hay ciertos personajes en la historia
que nacieron como talentosos
nos van haciendo creer que ciertas cosas
que han logrado en la historia son
inalcanzables para nosotros y no nos
enseñan como esas personas son iguales a
nosotros y lo único que nos diferencia
de nosotros es la manera en la que han
transmitido su mensaje con el mundo
por eso siento que es muy importante
analizar la vida de quienes admiramos en
este caso analizar cómo utilizaron ese
detonante ese fracaso esta tragedia ese
dolor y como lo convirtieron en el
legado que tenemos hasta hoy
/ frida kahlo y hitler dos personajes de
la historia que a mi parecer han
cambiado el mundo yo considero que hay
una sola diferencia la manera en la que
utilizaron su detonante la manera en la
que utilizaron toda esa energía que
tuvieron en sus vidas todo ese dolor que
sufrieron todo eso que le pasó en su
vida
a diferencia de que frida kahlo no los
enseña en obras de arte preciosas y
hitler transformó el mundo para mal
todos tenemos ese poder de cambiar el
mundo pero nosotros decidimos si va a
ser un cambio negativo o un cambio
positivo
así es como se que nosotros decidimos si
nuestro veneno se queda como veneno o si
lo transformamos en remedio
cuando el mundo estaba en guerra
nosotros sigamos bailando
esta es una obra que hice hace dos años
y es increíble como me sigue generando
los mismos sentimientos desde que la
hice
recuerdo un día levantarme y ver en las
noticias sobre un terrorismo en nueva
york'
de otro día sobre 50 personas que mueren
en la ciudad de orlando y cuál es la
causa una persona con mucho odio que
tenía mucho odio de los homosexuales
desaparecen tres estudiantes
muere una mujer por ir muy tarde en un
taxi
casos de odio esparcidos por todo el
mundo que me hacen sentarme y quedarme
pensando qué es lo que está pasando en
el mundo para que se esparza más sodio y
tampoco amor
me levanté otro día para dar una
conferencia en la ciudad de veracruz y
veo una amiga muy preocupada una amiga
que fue conmigo este viaje a veracruz y
me cuenta que uno de nuestros amigos de
culiacán
acaba de desaparecer y que no saben
dónde están
estoy dando mi conferencia
y la veo llorando
y ahí me doy cuenta que algo está mal me
acerco a ella
y me dice que acaban de asesinar a
nuestro amigo de la misma manera que
asesinaron a mi hermano unos años antes
ahí es donde mi corazón encuentra un
detonante para hablar de eso así como lo
hizo aquella vez a los 11 años
pero es muy difícil hablar este tipo de
situaciones sabiendo cómo hay personas
que utilizan este mismo detonante pero
para causar daño en los demás
y con esta foto yo intento expresar cómo
se que los seres humanos cada vez nos
volvemos más egoístas no nos damos
cuenta del daño que podemos causar en
las demás personas con simples acciones
no nos damos cuenta como el cambio más
grande y el problema más grande del país
y del mundo es la falta de empatía
y así es como me doy cuenta que cuando
el mundo está en guerra
nosotros solo seguimos bailando
en cada país que me toca visitar la
imagen que se tiene de sinaloa de
culiacán y de méxico siempre son las
mismas tres cosas me mencionó sobre los
narcos las drogas la violencia y para mí
es muy triste llevar mi trabajo otra
parte del mundo y que esto sea siempre
lo que me mencionen
y ahí es donde encontré mi cometido como
mexicana como persona y como artista
ahí es donde me di cuenta que los
artistas somos los valientes somos los
que tenemos esta voz y espero que algún
día como mexicano nos demos cuenta de
las voces tan importantes que tenemos en
el país y que están hablando por
nosotros en cualquier rincón del mundo
con cualquier profesión mexicanos que
son cineastas y que ganan oscars
deportistas
artistas doctores científicos cualquier
profesión que nos destaque que en mexico
y que nos está representando en otra
parte
después de años de tener el arte como
idioma principal me di cuenta como la
historia que te cuente yo en méxico lo
hace la misma que perciben en japón
porque lo que sufrimos y lo que somos
nunca va a ser lo mismo mis obras son un
espejo de lo que tú has vivido de lo que
tú percibes con aquellas cosas que lees
con aquellas cosas que ves con aquello
que disfrutas y aquello que te hace
sentir mal
después de tener el arte como idioma me
di cuenta de algo más importante
que si yo te transmito todos estos
sentimientos y si yo de esta manera te
platico mi adversidad y la intento sacar
de esta manera así como lo hicieron
aquellos artistas que admiro y
utilizaron su detonante para bien de
esta manera yo puedo hacer la voz ya que
el niño que vive con miedo
de aquella niña que asesinaron a su
hermano
ya que el hombre que vive con rencor y
que nunca supo cómo sacarlo en su vida
ya que el mexicano que quiere soñar pero
que no sabe cómo realizar sus sueños
y sobre todo la voz y las alas del
mexicano
yo te invito
a que encuentres ese detonante en tu
vida
qué juntes todas esas emociones que has
guardado por años que juntas todo ese
rencor que juntas todo ese odio que
alguna vez tuviste en tu vida
y que encuentres una manera de
transmitírselo a alguien de una manera
positiva que encuentres alguna manera de
sacarlo y que hagas algo con eso a
través de tu profesión a través de tu
misión de vida de tu cometido porque así
cuando el mundo esté en guerra no vamos
a seguir bailando
gracias
[Aplausos]